I worked nude offered to practice this
and I can remember once in my office
practicing it you know nude in the
corner and my wife Sue coming in and
opening the door and seeing her husband
huddled and you know a fetal position
nude on the floor first a little shock
and they should all know you're an actor
okay okay cause it kind of you know
confused the last picture show wing
Johnson oh the last picture show
I was sure lucky to get on board with
that one you know my agent said to have
a casting call I went out I think
according to Peter Bogdanovich I was the
first one cast you know every once in a
while you go through the door and they
say oh that's the guy and I guess that
was the case with me so I'd really
lucked out what a wonderful film that is
it's not like any movie and no movies
like it it's just sits there by itself
as far as preparing for the role there
was a young man he's about 16 years old
fella by the name of Lloyd Catlett hired
for a small part in the movie as well as
teaching us California kids how to be
Texas kids Lloyd did a wonderful job and
he kind of fell in love with the circus
you know with the movie biz and now it
turns out I don't know how many years
later that is 50 years later or whatever
in it Lord has been my stand-in for all
of those movies for over 60 films
together I was nominated for a Best
Supporting Actor that year for a blast
picture show these were in the days when
there was really no a campaign or
anything like that I remember it was
just a 19 year old kid somebody both
waking me up about 4 o'clock in the
morning said oh my god I couldn't
believe it
big surprise putting the boat in
Lightfoot Lightfoot and that was Michael
Jimmy nose first film that he directed
and he wrote it as well as you you might
know Clint Eastwood who was the producer
and star of that film he likes to do
maybe one or two takes
I was the punk kid who can I go to Mike
to me know I say I can't and I do you
guys do one more I gotta ask the boss
you know and so it would say I'll give
the kid a shot go
go ahead so I really appreciated that
and then later in the Heaven's Gate oh
gosh we would take you know 40 50 60
takes some time so it was quite a bit
different Michael Jimmy no I remember
now this I'm gonna kind of this is this
is gonna be a little kind of a long
story but it might be a good one that
was early on my career of this
thunderbolt and Lightfoot and I remember
being very anxious and I didn't really
feel like the character at all and I
went into Kamino
today before we shot and I was really
upset I said Mike I'm sorry I'm doing
this but I gotta tell ya I think you got
the wrong guy for this part I don't know
how to do this part and I I'm really you
know I don't feel like this guy at all
and he gave me a brilliant piece of
direction that I still hold close to my
heart he said you know the game tag and
I said yeah yeah he says well you're it
I think what do you mean he says you are
the guy there's no ifs ands or buts or
whatever you do that's what the guy does
yeah you're you're you're it tag you're
it King Kong
see I remember growing up in the
ditching high school or not in a high
school grammar school pretending I was
sick when I would look in the TV Guide
and see the King Kong that old you know
one from the 30s was on I love that
movie and so when I got offered the part
in the updated version I was all excited
about it we shot that movie for nine
months I think and it was a beautiful
location in kawaii and a wonderful cast
Charles Grodin Jessica Lange it was
Jessica Lange's first movie I believe
and I thought she just nailed to nailed
that part Rick Baker I think that was
one of his first big extravagant makeup
assignments he played the monkey for a
while and they had a big statue of the
monkey but I can remember one moment
where they had a giant hand that was
gonna hold and Jessica Lange the hand
was built in Italy and they had a
separate Italian fella on each finger to
move the faders like this and the
director John Gill irma he was very
frustrated because he would he would say
all right tighter tighter and then the
Italian guy would say all right
whoever tighter and it was very hard to
communicate so John Gill Herrmann
finally said just watch my hand and he
held his hand up over his head and he
had all these Italian guys on these
levers looking at John trying to end his
Jessica in the middle of this giant hand
and well you had to be there it sounds
frightened because he almost got crushed
to death you know but it was one of
those things that's humorous and
frightening all at the same time that
was a long-winded weird story I don't
know that bad cause one end
Stephen lists burger came up with this
idea of Tron what would it be like if a
person was sucked inside a computer and
Wow a wild idea and he had such a great
imagination back in the day when we did
the first Tron it was shot in
black-and-white 70 millimeter
black-and-white we were all on these
leotards with soccer helmets on I think
they were ice hockey helmets I can't
remember we were all encouraged to wear
colorful clothes to work because
everything was black and white when we
were shooting all hand tinted in Korea I
think you know later sequels are
wonderful when you have a character that
you get to play again and Tron's a good
example of that
Joe Kaczynski was the director of this
one it was his first movie can you
imagine directing a you know 200 million
dollar movie for your first movie but
Joe took me on to it like a duck to
water he created a great atmosphere was
very very easygoing and I think the film
turned out pretty good the star man yes
Tom man I remember going in for an
interview with John Carpenter the
director of that fell and I had this
idea of storm man who's was really
impersonating a human being as best as
he could it wasn't a very good
impersonation at first if he was leaning
on something for instance you know us
human beings we wiill it you know we
lean and there's a purpose to it but
star man would do that same thing but it
would be assuming the position but he
wouldn't put his weight on it that kind
of thing John seemed to like that
Oh often when I'm making a movie elf say
who of my friends remind me of this
character and I was looking through my
phonebook say what friend would I not be
surprised to find out was an alien from
another planet I came across this
wonderful fella Russell Clark was a
dancer and we worked quite a bit on that
beginning scene when star man is being
born and I figured if I could get that
in his movements then I could just
gradually become more human as the movie
went on Karen Allen was just remarkable
in that movie if you're playing a king
in a movie and nobody's treating you
like a king well then you ain't a king
you know and that goes for being an
alien in the movie too and she made it
all all come together made it all so
real The Big Lebowski played the dude
what can I say let's see gosh such a
good time I've got to work with my good
buddy t-bone Burnett who did all that
wonderful music and of course the Coen
brothers you know God those guys they're
their masters you know they make it look
so easy and it's such just such a
terrific movie you know I'm another guy
who looks at a lot of my movies on TV or
whatever but when that movie comes on I
get hooked
you know I I'll say I'll just watch it
you know just watch till tuturro licks
the ball and then I'll you know click
I'm a clicker guy going something else
but then I'll say oh no I'll just wait
for that's in there and I ended up
watching the whole thing it's just made
so well that that film years later a
friend of mine Bernie Glassman who
happened to be a Zen master said you
realize in many circles the dude is
considered a Zen master I said what are
you talking about we never talked
spirituality or Buddhism or nothing I
said he says oh yeah who wrote and
directed the film the Coen brothers a
Coen are these Zen questions like you
know what is the sound of one hand
clapping these sort of things and he
says that movie The Big Lebowski is
filled of modern-day Cohens I said
really he said sure you're like the dude
abides that's it
Buddhist kind of thought or that's just
like your opinion man the Coen brothers
you know there's such terrific writers I
find a lot of people you know are
wondering if there was a lot of improv
in that movie because it's kind of the
dialogue seem so natural and no there
was not it was all down the page every
[ __ ] every man you wanted him in the
right spot because it was like music in
rehearsal we would improv to kind of
find the life of the same but when it
got down to shooting I mean I was always
looking at the strip to find out where
the man is you know where the f-bomb is
you know those guys the Masters True
Grit Rooster Cogburn True Grit well I
get to work with the Cohens again that
was you know so so wonderful great cast
Josh Brolin and Hailee Steinfeld just
nailed that that part very difficult
part you know I get to ride - man I get
to do that baby put that you know
playing cowboys contender president
Jetson I'm pretty fussy you know I try
to work as little as possible you know
because I know what it implies yeah
you're gonna work and it takes you away
from your family and all your other
interests and also it when you do in
that movie you're unable to do this
movie coming down the pike that you
don't even sure what that movie is but
you might like it better so I really try
to hold out as long as I can
prior to the getting the script of the
contender I'd held out pretty long time
and I read that script and I remember
yelling out to my wife
sue I think we got one it's wonderful in
the film when the writer knows the world
that he's writing about
Ron Laurie really knew what he was
talking about he was a reporter and he
got into the reporting business so he
could talk to filmmakers because he was
really interested in directing films
then the other big plus for that movie
was working with Joan Allen who I'd
worked with in Tucker years before she
played my wife and that hearing I was
getting it support her in this wonderful
role as far as you know role models for
that film you know who I used is my
father Lloyd Bridges who I learned all
my basics from my dad acting basics but
the main thing I learned from him was
something not in words or anything like
that but just observing how he was when
he worked on a set he enjoyed this thing
that we do so much that it was
contagious and I kind of spread through
the company and if oh yeah this is kind
of fun and I thought that was the same
kind of energy that this president
President Jackson had I think and
Clinton the editor he really enjoyed
being president you know and I think
Jackson did too Iron Man is staged well
a lot of funny memories come to me John
Favreau and Robert Downey jr. were on
board and we thought the script needed a
lot of work
we had two weeks of rehearsal and we met
together and we really ironed the thing
out quite well I'm we all fought and
then a day before shooting we get a
message from the Marvel folks this was
Marvel's first superhero movie they said
oh no no no either script you changed it
all wrong we said oh my god what are we
gonna do well what we did is that we
would often meet in my trailer before
work for two or three hours trying to
figure out what we're gonna shoot that
day there was no script
you know the crew would be in there
tapping their foot waiting for us and
we'd be in there you know playing each
other's parts and improvising you know
John would be calling the writer friends
of his and it was driving me absolutely
crazy you know I I like to know my lines
until I'm
a little adjustment inside and it turned
it all around and that little adjustment
was me talking to myself and just said
Jeff please relax you are making a 200
million dollar student film that's it
just have fun you know you've got John
Favreau and Downey they're so good man
relax and have fun I said oh that's
right so that's what we did we just
jammed had a great time and I think it's
up there on the on the screen
you got Downey who was a master and
Favreau he's so skilled at so many
things that are important making a movie
not only is he great improviser and
actor and writer and director and all
that stuff but he can talk with the
suits you know he knows how to not blow
it and get the job done and you know
look at his movies it's wonderful crazy
hard bad play crazy hot ah man
again got to work with my good buddy
t-bone t-bone Burnett I remember turning
that movie down quite a few times
because there was no music to it so I
thought oh you know it would be great to
do a musician a little playing guitar
but the fact they don't have to be music
I can let that one go and then I ran
into my buddy t-bone and he said what do
you think about this crazy heart script
I said well there's no music dude he
says oh that's the easy part
I said what are you interested in doing
is it but I'll do it if you'll do it and
I said really so off we went and such a
joyous experience Scott Cooper it was
his first movie that he wrote and
directed he's by far one of my favorite
directors to work with the part of
playing a you know a country singer was
so wonderful I've been playing guitar
since I've been a kid it opened to my my
music world in such a beautiful way I
have a band I go out in the road with
now called the abiders and that all I
think all that came from crazy heart
hell or high water
Wow hell or high water david mckenzie
great director I was a big fan of his
film called startup and I figure this
guy is gonna do wonderful and many sure
did oh one of the great pleasures for me
in that movie was working with Gil
Birmingham who I had most of my scenes
with wonderful actor you know you're
very lucky when you're making the movie
when you get an authentic version of the
guy here plan and we were so fortunate
to have walking Jackson who is one of
the foremost Texas Rangers on board oh
man he taught me so much not only you
know how the guys look in their attitude
but just being in them proximity one of
those guys you seem to know something
just kind of comes over when they open
when they're open to you you know and
what keen certainly was bad times at the
El Royale
father Daniel Flynn it's wonderful when
you when the writer and director of the
same person you know because you got the
source there directing you on the thing
and when you get a director like Drew
who is a very strong opinion of how it
should go but he's also open to
everybody else's ideas that's my
favorite and drew was certainly that
type of director and really created a
great environment on the set for assault
of to have a good time and you know do
our best work by keeping us relaxed you
know but the movie is by no means a
relaxed kind of movie there's lots of
twists and turns and a lot of surprises
it was more the story than the character
I love what the story was saying with
the movie was saying I enjoyed working
with the Nick Offerman who played my
brother and all the guys you know Jon
Hamm Chris Hemsworth what wonderful cast
jeez I've made a lot of good movies huh
you